hypersensitivity is a oversensitive
state of the immune system
if you personify our immune system then
you might think that during
hypersensitivity our immune system over
react to exposure to any pathogen or
sometimes to the self antigens as well
and it increase the risk of autoimmune
disorders and sometimes it is extremely
uncomfortable and occasionally fatal so
it's a dangerous aspects of the immune
system in this video we'll talk about
type 3 hypersensitivity which is
prevalently immune complex mediated now
before learning about more this type 3
hypersensitivity we should little bit
think about what happens during the
complement pathway and how type 3
hypersensitivity is involved in that so
let's say there is a bacteria and this
is a harmful one so there are antibodies
deposited against specific epitopes on
these bacterial surfaces which in
interns attract c1q and the c1q
complement convertase protein right and
then it Cleaves several complement
proteins such as c4 which give rise to C
for AAC for P it also Cleaves C to and
many other complement proteins now
eventually there are other membrane
associated converters complex known as
c3 and c5 convertase complex which
convert further complement proteins into
cleaved format now out of these
compliment protein like c3 AC to AC for
a these are put into an aflatoxin that
means they can be secreted from the
bacteria and then they can go to nearby
blood vessels which allow them to like
mobilize neutrophil and the macrophage
to the site of these bacterial infection
and this neutrophils and macrophages v's
bacterial bacteria which are harmful
because they have it's a receptor which
can bind to the
well bind to the antibodies which are
coating the bacteria now one hand side
complement fixation can itself damage
the bacteria now there are several
complexes such as C 3 C 3 B these
complexes attract macrophages and
macrophages have seen 3b receptor
against that so it helps the macrophage
to get more directed towards the
bacteria and engulf it otherwise with a
combination of all sort of complement
proteins in a cascade it creates a
membrane pore complex in this membrane
attack complex it leads to osmotic disk
balance and thereby lysis of the
bacteria and thereby the bacteria is
killed most of the cases these
complement proteins and the bacteria are
cleared by the macrophages or the
neutrophils they are cleared by the
scavenging system and thereby it cannot
harm nearby cells the complement
proteins cannot harm the nearby cells
but in case of type 3 hypersensitivity
reaction what happens is there is too
much production of these complement
proteins and the complement complexes as
a result it is not cleared from the
system and somewhere it gets circulated
into the bloodstream and somewhere gets
deposited into the blood into the blood
vessels and create consequences in order
to understand that we take an example
let's say a snake has bitten you now you
know this snake is poisonous snake so it
would have toxin and this toxin is
entered your bloodstream in order to
neutralize this toxin you need an
antibody which would be eventually
cleared up and neutralizing this toxin
so this toxin cannot do what it is
supposed to do now you would inject
yourself with an antiserum now the
antiserum is nothing but an T serum from
an animal which is previously bitten by
this name same snake so clearly this
antiserum would neutralize the antigen
and thereby save your body but the
problem is
this serum is derived from an animal
which is either rabbit let's say our
mouse something like that but this
species of active body would be detected
as foreign in your system now your
system would mount an immune response
against that and what would happen the
antibodies would be itself serving like
an antigen and several antibodies would
be producing produced against them now
most of the cases these big complexes
are cleared out by the macrophages
because it has if see receptors but when
it is produced in very high amount my
professors cannot clear all of these
mess as a result macrophages and
neutrophils
try to clear it but several of these
immune complexes circulate around the
bloodstream now what happens is that
they get deposited onto the blood vessel
wall and once they are deposited into
the blood vessel wall first thing they
can do is attract neutrophils basophils
and many other granulocyte which would
eventually secret several cytokines
which are pro-inflammatory like in
interleukin 6 interleukin 1 not only it
would attract more such immune cells to
the site but it would also have damaging
effects to the blood vessel wall it can
also lead to vasodilation and later on
shows several symptoms of inflammation
these immune complexes are specially
relevant in case of an autoimmune
disease like rheumatoid arthritis in
rumored arthritis a complex of
complement proteins IgG IgM etc are
deposited in the joints and which mounts
a huge immune response and inflammatory
response in this joint which would lead
to deformity of the joint and
degradation of the Brom bone structure
this this is actually due to a type 3
hypersensitive response not only this
lupus and many other things may
farmers didi disease all these things
are actually examples of type three
hypersensitive response and all of these
disease has a common theme with the
increased or hiked immune response that
our body display is due to excessive
production of these complement and
complement cascade proteins and a
complex of complement and antibody
reactions this was a video on overview
of type 3 hypersensitivity I hope you
liked this video if you liked this video
give it a big thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you